right in a brand new series we are
exploring what the next decade will
bring for everything from climate change
to health and we are kicking it off with
a look at the 2020s in tech the last 10
years have changed the way we get music
movies and news the decade saw the
arrival of the Amazon echo and the rise
of Spotify and Netflix meanwhile uber
lyft and Airbnb transformed how we
travel so what could be next in this
next decade CBS News contributor and
wired editor-in-chief Nicholas Thompson
is here with a peek into the future Wow
good morning that's valuable ok one of
the things that comes up is 5g which a
super fast internet superfast internet
right so we connect right now with 4G
your phone or your device connects to a
big tower on top of the hill sends a
signal down relatively slow 5g smaller
base stations different technology but
the key point these things will go about
fifty a hundred times faster once it's
fully implemented and we have no idea
what we'll be able to create when we can
send information 50 to 100 times faster
the last time with 4G that's why we got
Eber that's why we got all of the things
in the last decade you don't think about
that uber wouldn't have work maybe
Instagram wouldn't even worked with Fort
with 3G once we got to 4G all that stuff
was possible with 5g it won't just be
you'll get your email faster because
that doesn't matter it'll be something
we haven't imagined yet so you're like
in 5g then oh I'm so in I want our
country to get 5g faster it's actually
nationally important yes other countries
are moving more quickly US needs to get
on it
awesome Gayle what about here sure shall
I call President Xi Nick what about AI
and jobs yeah because AI scares a lot of
people but you're saying we need to get
ready what does it mean when it comes to
jobs so an incredibly complicated
incredibly important question for the
next decade my guess is that AI will
create more new jobs than the jobs of
displaces but there will be a lot of
jobs that are changed and that are
transformed particularly jobs that are
repetitive that don't involve a bunch of
sort of spontaneous creative decisions
the way I like to look at it is imagine
you have to write a manual for your job
if the manual is a page or two pages or
three pages you kind of do this and you
do that
a computer will probably do that in the
next decade what's the concern there
with AI jobs I guess when you think
about they're creating jobs in some ways
but then they're taking away they will
create fantastic jobs but one of the
risks is you can have whole categories
people often talk about truck drivers if
we have self-driving trucks what does a
truck driver gonna do if that job isn't
possible well you have to retrain and
find something else but that can be hard
depending on what stage in life you're
in so over CEO is talking about flying
cars trying to get used to self the idea
of self-driving cars flying cars in 2023
do you see that not in 2000 Eric sees it
we might have self-driving cars in 2023
they will be awesome but it lacks our
ease Nick flying cars are definitely
possible think of them more as single
person helicopters better for the
environment like as we keep talking
about climb it's better for traffic I
think we can work on the environment in
other areas ok well I'm getting big
issue with transportation we have huge
issues with transportation and in fact
self-driving cars it could be better for
the environment because using 5g they
can all talk to each other so they can
travel right behind each other
reducing wind resistance therefore
increasing fuel efficiency so go back to
flying cars yes do you see this please
do you do you see that happy yes
absolutely in my life not by 2023 by
2030 I in 2020 29 we're gonna do this
segment again and I am going to get here
from Brooklyn to West 57th in a flying
car Gail okay Erin
[Laughter]